hey guys did you know that you tell
people
a lot about yourself with just
your body language especially your
posture
without you even realizing it now good
posture will not just improve the way
that you look
but it helps to build strength
flexibility and balance in your body
and this all reduces that stress that
bad body posture puts on
your muscles ligaments and spine and it
causes most of the
back and shoulder and neck pain that
people get without them even
realizing they don't understand that
it's actually their bad
posture and you can fix it now if you
always
slouch it not only puts a lot of
stress on your backbone but also smashes
your organs together
and it makes it difficult for your
intestines and your lungs to work
effectively
and if you do this for too long you
might get problems in breathing
and digesting food now apart from that
let's talk about appearance the way you
present yourself to other people
if you improve your body posture it will
improve
the way that you look your appearance
your chin and neckline will look more
defined your chest will look better and
more prominent
you will look more athletic and you will
look more confident and ready
to take on the world so how do you do
this how do you improve your bad
body posture well i'm gonna explain it
to you
i have a dream that's all i need
but mistakes make you strong now the
first thing that you need to know is the
difference between good posture and bad
posture
bad posture usually comes from bad
habits
things like sitting too long in front of
a desk working on a laptop
using your phone too much watching tv or
even driving
the car now of all of these things
happening to you every single day these
bad habits
gravity brings you down so it looks like
this
and you let it happen so your back bends
forwards
your shoulders come with it that goes
forward and your neck as well
it goes forward a little bit down this
is bad body posture
you don't want this what you want is
this
straight back straight shoulders not to
the front but
back and a straight neck not forward but
here
now i get it it does look weird if you
walk like this everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
but you do need to improve your posture
as much
as possible so that you can still look
natural
and not weird now the first thing that
you need to do is to get rid of your bad
habits this is the most important thing
that you have to start with
every time you catch yourself slouching
while you sit and work on the computer
sit up straight when you catch yourself
looking at your phone with your head
forward and down
bring your phone up and make your neck
straight now
the second thing that you can do to
improve your bad body posture
is stretching exercises now
there are actually many that you can do
and they all work great but i'm just
gonna give you the seven
best according to me of course so let's
start with the first one
now this one is easy all you need is a
door frame all you need to do is stand
in front of the door frame
take one step forward with your body
weight on it and bring your arms
up above your head hold it there for
about
15 to 30 seconds you'll feel your pec
stretch and your back straightening as
well
now you can hold your arms here at
different positions so lower your arms a
little
right next to you and keep it there for
15 seconds and lastly lower it even more
and keep it there for 15
seconds so this helps you to get out of
this slouchy forward position
to open up your back is straight your
shoulders is back and straight
your neck is up and straight as well
this is what you want
the second stretch you can easily do at
home works for your lower back
and this is the superman lay down on the
floor then raise your legs off the
ground
and stretch your arms out right in front
of you do three sets of 12 reps
the next exercise is going to help these
back muscles that's been
weakened because of this forward slouchy
movement all the time
and this muscle group is called the
thoracic area so how are you going to
stretch it and make it stronger
face pulls you can do face pulls at the
gym or at home with a resistance band
if you don't go to the gym if you work
out at home and you want a resistance
band i'll add some good options for you
in the video description down below
as always but you can also work out
these muscles
without any equipment at home with the
door frame
all you got to do is stand in front of
the door frame arms on the frame
lean back and pull yourself forward
another great exercise is that you can
stretch your back with a foam
roller if you don't have one then i'll
add one for in the video description
that you can check out
but then again if you don't want to buy
one you can just use
towels just take three to four towels
together and roll them up
then just put them on the ground lay
down on it with your spine
all the way from your tailbone to your
head and if the towels are too short
just get a pillow for your head now you
can use another towel or a broom or even
a golf club
and move it with both hands from your
legs over your head
and back again and then you just do this
slowly for one to two minutes depending
on how your body feels
now if for some reason you don't have
another towel or a broomstick or
whatever to use
with both hands then you can also do
angel stretches
so start by moving your arms from the
bottom next to your sides
all the way up over your head and back
and again do this for one to two minutes
another exercise that you can do if for
some reason you don't like lying on the
floor
is the wall posture exercise if you
can't do this
really well then you know that your
posture is probably not good
or your body is too stiff you can
actually do this with me right now
go to the wall put your hips back
shoulders
and head against the wall now your whole
body posture
will be in the right position your feet
can actually be a few inches
away from the wall remember not to tilt
your head
or chin down head straight and chin up
now we're gonna do snow angels or some
people call them butterflies
but not the full movement alright bring
your arms up next to you
against the wall with your elbows and
the back of your hands
against the wall now move your arms over
your head
and back again now if you've got a
stability ball at home then
use it because it's great for your body
posture
if you want one at home then i'll add
one for in the video description that
you can check out now all you gotta do
is get on it drop your hips off the ball
as much as you can
bring your arms up straight over your
head and just lay over the ball
and stay there for 10 to 30 seconds
depending
on how your body feels now if you don't
have a stability ball
if you don't want one then just hang i
really mean just
a hand you can do it at the gym before
you do your pull-ups
just hang on the pull-up bar
[Music]
with your feet back and stretch your
front side
you can do this for 30 to 50 seconds
depending on how your body feels
now apart from those bad habits that you
have to leave and
the stretching exercises that you can do
to improve your body posture
you can also get these mesh back support
cushion things for your chair
my wife and i use them all the time and
it makes a
big difference you don't have to sit
with bad posture
and back pain the whole day while
working and as always i'll add it for
you in the video description so you can
check it out
now if you really struggle with bad body
posture then you can get
a back posture support brace like this
one
many people use it and love it you can
check out all the great customer reviews
about it on
amazon now always remember this good
styling
good grooming and great body posture
always needs to go hand in hand
cheers guys